FOR THE LAST TWO
SEASONS.
>> BENEFITTED FROM A
DIFFERENT TYPE OS RAKEL
JOHANSS
NUMBER FOUR IS HAYDN
FLEURY, PLAYED IN 12
GA
NEVER TOO LATE TO COME
BACK.
BACKDALE'S PASS BLOCKED
OFF.
HERE COMES WENNBERG FOR.
EDDIE: HE HAD HIMSELF A
LOT ABOUT IT.
DIRECT THE PUC
THROUGH.
NOW HE DOES.
THT SHIFT BY
SEATTLE OFFENSIVELY.THE
ZEGRAS BIDES TIME,
WAITS, AND PATIENTLY
FIRES.
TEAM.
YOU CAN FORCE RIGHT
AHEAD BY GRANT.
GRANT MADE A GREAT COUN.
>> YES, THEY D D
CHANGE AND IT WAS NOT.
KEEP AN EYE ON THE.
KENNY: THE CLASSIC, WILD
INSIDE THE DOTS.
EBERLE.
BLOCKED OFF IN FRONT.
McCANN THA THEY
GET THIS OPPORTUNITY.
ON THE RIGHT PART OF T
PLAY.
THAT'S THE WAY YOU HAVE
TO THINK.
LET'S GET THE NEXT PENA
RIGHT PART OF YOUR
SCREEN.
HE GETS IT, THE
E ASSIST ON THE DONATO
S
KENNY:E KRAKEN BY A
3-1 SCORE.
2:43 GONE HERE IN THE
THIRD.
EDDIE: YOU WILL SEE THE.
REMAINING IN REGULATION.
HE LOOKS LIKE HE'SCARRIN
4-1..
DONSKOI COMES OVER.
DRIE